feu de chaume incendie de culture un
mois de juillet difficile pour les
agriculteurs fortes chaleurs et moisson
ne font pas bon ménage au service
départemental d'incendié et de secours
de l'yonne 125 incendies ont été
recensés depuis le début du mois on a un
nombre d'incendiés notamment les feux de
chaume et les feux de l'espace naturel
ce qu'on appelle soit en légère hausse
puisque en légère hausse puisque
normalement nous avons 7 % des incendies
et là on est à 15 % des incendies sur
ses trois premières semaines
les bons jours un mois de juillet
particulièrement dense pour les
opérateurs du sdiss qui doivent parvenir
à déterminer au plus vite le type
d'intervention et sa localisation du
chocolat bon d'accord c'est quoi qui
brûlent monsieur comme ouais d'accord et
c'est insensé de la récolte une fois les
informations recueillies et l' incendie
localiser le logiciel va sélectionner le
centre de secours le plus proche
tout en vérifiant la disponibilité des
équipes en temps réel s'ils sont de
secours le plus proche
y'a pas de pompiers surtout à 112
courroucé des sapeurs pompiers
volontaires
s'il ya pas de pompiers en journée parce
qu'ils sont tous au travail il va
sélectionner le centre de secours
le deuxième appel le plus proche et
ainsi de suite jusqu'à ce qu'ils
arrivent à trouver
mason de secours programmé armée l'engin
et partir sur sinistre au centre de
secours
les équipes reçoivent toutes les
informations nécessaires pour partir
malgré un nombre d'interventions en
hausse les casernes doit faire face à
une diminution des effectifs
professionnels durant l'été on travaille
avec les deux tiers de l'effectif le
tiers étant en congés on a néanmoins des
renforts de sapeur-pompier volontaire
des renforts de sapeurs-pompiers
contractuels saisonniers qui nous aide
durant cette période maintenir
l'effectif et donc à garantir une
qualité opérationnelle de tout instant
avec la fin des moissons et la
diminution des températures dans l'yonne
le nombre d' incendies devraient
diminuer dans les prochains jours
même si l'été est loin d'être terminée
[Musique]